[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight beta or Roarke we are
sad to tell you has changed he's not the
boyish carefree Road Trip er with the
primo we'd hook up you might remember
from just a few months ago that bado is
gone maybe forever the new bado is far
more serious even angry what's the new
bait Oh mad about will climate change
obviously in border walls and bigotry
and uptight old people who don't
understand that skateboarding is not a
crime
also that buzzkill Peabody judge or
whatever his name is who snuck up and
stole his spot in the presidential
rankings that was annoying as hell but
mostly what bado is mad at is bado
Beto's had some free time recently being
unemployed so he looked inside and came
to the conclusion that actually he's a
pretty mediocre person not a good guy at
all pretty much an awful human being
most people would keep that knowledge to
themselves not bado
he went on the view today to tell
everyone did a Vanity Fair cover to
announce your campaign and you said you
were quote born to be in it you went
across the country alone on a road trip
after you lost your election and you
said you quote sometimes help raise your
kids these are things in my mind that a
female candidate wouldn't be able to get
away with do you think you can get away
with more because you're a man and do
you have any regrets about launching on
the cover of Vanity Fair you're right
there are things that I have been
privileged to do in my life
that others cannot you're right said
bado male privilege is real I should
know all those cool fun things I've done
in my life I only did them because I'm a
man and I feel bad about that so bad
that I've had a Committee of diversity
consultants draft an awkwardly written
statement of moral culpability which I
will now read to you with feigned
sincerity in the hope that it's
sufficient atonement for my sins here we
go
the systemic foundational discrimination
that we have in this country in every
aspect of life is something that I have
not experienced in my lifetime and I've
had advantages that others could not
enjoy yes well I clears that up in case
you thought the bado
might be suffering from systemic
foundational discrimination in every
aspect of his life now you know the
truth he's not and he's deeply ashamed
of that because it's morally superior to
be discriminated against as the rich and
pampered ladies of the view who are also
somehow victims can and will tell you
but whatever bado can't help it if
people don't hate him for who he is
that's the downside of privileged people
like you too much
albedo can do is try harder to be
despised as much as he despises himself
which he has pledged to do I have my
work cut out for me to be a better
person and ensure that I'm more mindful
to the experiences that others have had
different than the experiences that
those mistakes would you say those are
mistakes being on the cover of Vanity
Fair yes oh so maybe it's elitist what
what yeah yeah I think it reinforces
that that perception of privilege and
that headline that said I was I was born
to be in this side in the articles
attempting to say that that I felt that
my calling was in public service no one
is born to be President of the United
States of America least of all me so so
dad thing yeah I deserved it just so
we're clear on this the lady who makes
millions talking about herself on a TV
show every day disapproves of baito
appearing on a magazine cover because
it's quote elitist and bado fervently
agrees with her of course he does there
is no criticism of bado that bado does
not agree with back in March he
apologized profusely for saying that his
wife had raised their three kids do you
even know how patriarchal that sounds
bado does and he's really truly
sincerely sorry he said it
but I'll be much more thoughtful going
forward in the way that I talked about
our marriage and also the way in which I
acknowledge the truth I have enjoyed
white privilege there you go he
acknowledged it Thank You mr. O'Rourke
for your candor but the real question is
how much did you enjoy white privilege
we'll get to those details in our next
round of questioning but in the meantime
we don't want to give you the impression
that bado is the only one groveling here
far from it they all are for Democrats
in 2019 to run is to grovel
here's mayor Pete of South Bend
remembering with sadness and horror the
one time years ago when he suggested
that all human life had value how could
he have been so stupid and cruel 2015
you said that all lives matter when you
spoke about two police controversies
that were happening in South Bend was
that a mistake what I did not understand
at that time was that that phrase just
early into the especially 2015 was
coming to be viewed as a sort of counter
slogan to black lives matter and so this
statement that scene is very anodyne and
did something that nobody could be
against Ashlee wound up being used to
devalue what the black lives matter
movement was telling us since learning
about how that phrase was being used to
push back on that activism I've stopped
using it in that context yeah I've
stopped how could I have been so stupid
and here's senator Kirsten Gillibrand of
New York calling in artillery on her own
position after an NBC researcher
discovered that she had once supported
national border seriously he essentially
said that you were embarrassed about
your previous position on immigration
tell me about that well I don't think it
was driven from my heart I was callous
to the suffering of families who want to
be with their loved ones people who want
to be reunited with their families and I
recognize as we all do that immigration
and diversity is our strength as a
country I really regretted that I didn't
look beyond my district and talk about
why this is an important part of the
United States story I was callous I was
heartless don't hate me I hate myself in
enough well thank you for sharing
Kirsten good luck with your self-esteem
issues Joe Biden is a good quarter
century older than senator Gillibrand
who herself is older than a lot of the
Democratic candidates so you'd think
Biden would be old enough he would have
earned the right not to say he's sorry
but think again ages now itself
something to apologize for and Biden did
Biden grew up at a time before human
warmth was reclassified as a criminal
act and he's very very sorry for that
social waters have began to change their
ship and the boundaries of protecting
personal space have been reset and I get
it I get it
I hear what they're saying that will be
more mindful respectful of people's
personal space
we could go on with the orgy of apology
Kamla Harris apologizing for putting
criminals in jail Bernie Sanders
apologizing for how women were treated
on his last campaign even as he denied
they were mistreated Amy Klobuchar are
apologizing for once wanting pizza in
school lunches etc tomorrow all of them
will be apologizing for something new in
a world without forgiveness this is a
cycle that continues forever no self
abasement is ever enough the left has
become a kind of rolling inquisition
with the bottomless appetite for ritual
punishment and humiliation tell us
you've been naughty
thank you sir may I have another this is
sick these people have no dignity they
have no self-respect there is nothing
they won't say nothing they won't admit
to whether it's true or not
they despise themselves be careful of
people like that
they're likely to feel the same way
about you